manhattan district attorney sai vance
has convened a special grand jury to
hear evidence about potential charges
against members of the trump
organization
and potentially the trump family reached
for comment the former president said
absolutely everyone says my juries are
the grandest juries anyone has ever seen
big beautiful juries the likes of which
no one has ever seen my juries are at
least
100 grand everyone says so what is a
grand jury in the first place and is
donald trump really in trouble this time
or what well it kinda
[Music]
sponsored by ting mobile hey legal
eagles it's time to think like a
district attorney
now what are the responsibilities of
grand jurors how much influence does a
prosecutor have
and what is the situation for trump and
his employees today we're going to learn
the ins and outs of the grand jury
process
in new york but the first question is
how easy is it to indict someone with a
grand jury well
former new york state chief judge seoul
walker once said the prosecutors had so
much control over the grand jury that
by and large they could get them to
indict a ham sandwich
now this phrase has become shorthand for
prosecutors ability to get grand juries
to do whatever they want
and as we'll discuss later on in this
video that control can go both ways and
ironically wackler himself
was later indicted for hush money
payments to a mistress
but back to the story at hand what is
going on with trump well the washington
post reported that a manhattan grand
jury had
recently started to meet to review
potential charges against the trump
organization
and its principles some of this
information is not entirely new vance's
office has been investigating the trump
organization for about two years
we don't know all of the details but tax
fraud and campaign finance violations
are both on the table
former trump lawyer michael cohen has
been interviewed eight times by vance's
office
and cohen has discussed hush money
payments he allegedly made to trump's
mistresses in addition to providing
background on how trump's businesses
were
operated last year i did a video about
the explosive allegations of trump tax
fraud by the new york times
vance's office is believed to be looking
at whether trump or his employees lied
about the value of assets to gain
favorable loan terms and tax benefits
vance's investigation got a boost
earlier this year after the supreme
court ruled that trump had to turn over
eight years of tax records
reports say that these records include
both the final and draft version of tax
returns and this information would be
central to any determination that trump
himself
had criminal liability especially with
regards to his mental state
when these financial documents were
filed and as i discussed in the video
about trump's taxes
it's not easy to prove tax fraud tax
fraud turns on whether the person filing
the return
knew that they were committing fraud
powerful people like ceos and mob bosses
are usually pretty savvy about speaking
in code and shifting responsibility to
others in the hierarchy like
cohen or cfo of the trump organization
alan weisselberg
for instance i mean we don't know what
is actually happening inside the trump
organization at this time
but that's why we should be wary about
drawing firm conclusions about whether
the grand jury will find evidence that
trump had an intent to commit crimes but
it is a possibility so the question is
what is this grand jury that's looking
at trump
actually doing right now well first we
have to start with what is a grand jury
a grand jury is a group of citizens who
must decide whether there's enough
evidence for a person to be charged with
a crime
it's a very different proceeding than
the jury trials you're probably used to
seeing on tv so
let's start with the difference between
a petty jury and a grand jury
a petty jury is convened to decide
whether someone has committed a crime or
a defendant has
civil liability petty juries listen to
the evidence presented by both parties
during a trial
and then return a verdict if a petty
jury finds a defendant guilty then
they'll be sentenced typically with a
fine imprisonment or a combination of
both
a petty jury is the jury that you're
probably used to seeing on tv
in contrast a grand jury does not
determine someone's guilt or
innocence it also has no involvement in
civil cases this is a purely criminal
issue a grand jury hears evidence
presented by a prosecutor that
jury must determine whether there is
probable cause to believe that the
person or entity has committed a crime
if the grand jury decides that there is
probable cause then it will file a
written statement of a charge this is
called an indictment
if the grand jury finds probable cause
then the defendant will be formally
charged with a crime
and potentially there will be an actual
criminal trial to determine their guilt
or
innocence now this isn't the way that it
happens in every case or in
every state some states use what's
called an information which is basically
just an indictment that comes directly
from the district attorney with no need
for
the involvement of a grand jury but
let's talk about new york law
in the new york constitution article 1
section 6 says that no defendant
may be tried for a felony without the
case first having been presented to
a grand jury a new york grand jury is
composed of between 23
and 16 people these people are summoned
the same way that anyone is for jury
duty with a notice from a county clerk
the jurors usually have to serve a term
that ranges from between two weeks and
several months and a special grand jury
can meet for up to six months and since
this proceeding doesn't determine
someone's guilt it only determines
whether there's probable cause for an
indictment
you don't have a lot of the safeguards
that you would normally have in a
full-blown criminal trial
for example under new york law there's
no judge presiding in the room during
the grand jury proceedings
the prosecutor is in charge and is
therefore responsible for presenting the
government's case
and reading the law to the grand jury
this means that psy vance's office has
two roles first
presenting evidence as a district
attorney for manhattan and advising the
grand jury about process
the d.a takes on the role of a judge by
advising the jury in ruling on the
admissibility of evidence and answering
questions
hopefully the d.a will act in good faith
but if he believes that there's probable
cause he's going to present evidence
advocating for an indictment this is why
grand juries are so one-sided
so who is in this secretive grand jury
room
well usually it's the jurors the
prosecutor and a court reporter
witnesses are only present during
questioning the defendant and his or her
lawyers are generally not present but
we'll get to an exception to that
and when the jury deliberates the
prosecutors and court reporter leave the
room
grand jurors can ask questions which is
something that doesn't happen during
criminal trial proceedings
however the prosecutor then puts on the
judge hat and decides whether the
question
is relevant and in a federal grand jury
yes the federal prosecutors are bound by
a similar procedure the prosecutor's not
constrained by the rules of evidence
that apply during a criminal trial
but in new york the prosecutor is bound
by the state's rules of evidence with a
few noteworthy exceptions which give
more leeway for hearsay testimony
if someone is indicted based on hearsay
testimony prosecutors will then have to
develop non-hearsay evidence
for the criminal case now i know this
sounds incredibly one-sided but remember
there's still a criminal trial
yet to happen this is only deciding
about a potential indictment and
traditionally a potential defendant had
no right to testify in his or her
defense
in front of a grand jury but defendants
in new york do have a right to testify
before the grand jury but
this is almost never a good idea because
the bar is so low to get an indictment
for example new york criminal procedure
law section 190.50 provides that a
potential defendant must be permitted to
testify before a grand jury
but the potential defendant has to sign
and submit a waiver of immunity and a
waiver of his or her fifth amendment
right against self-incrimination
and there's very little benefit to
testifying before a grand jury a
potential defendant won't know the
extent of the government's case against
them and
unlike a criminal trial process where
the evidence is established well in
advance of trial and the prosecutor has
an obligation to give that evidence to
the defendant
here the person's testimony could tip
off the prosecutor about additional
evidence
and witnesses and potentially worst of
all the defendant's testimony could also
be used
in a future criminal trial meaning that
the evidence the person blindly offers
during a grand jury proceeding
could be highly damning and used against
them in the future
believe me former president trump does
not want to testify before
any grand jury even though as i'm sure
he would say the testimony would be
beautiful
perfect testimony and perhaps most
importantly at the conclusion of the
proceedings jurors will vote on whether
there is probable cause that the
potential defendant committed a crime
they vote on whether to return what is
called a true bill authorizing
prosecutors to indict the defendant
and in a grand jury prosecutors don't
need a unanimous grand jury an
affirmative vote of just 12 grand jurors
is enough to authorize an indictment
and if 12 jurors don't believe enough
evidence exists to charge a person then
they can return what's called a
no bill which prevents indictment but
that's
pretty unlikely but either way
everything related to the proceeding is
supposed to be sealed and secret which
is interesting given that there were
leaks that led to the washington post
reporting that the grand jury exists and
is in process
but let's talk about secrecy in these
grand jury proceedings
both state and federal grand juries are
conducted in secrecy the supreme court
has laid out many reasons for secret
proceedings number one
prevents the escape of potential
defendants it ensures that the jurors
are not pressured by their friends or
threatened with retaliation by potential
defendants
it discourages perjury and encourages
people to testify without fear
and it protects potential defendants who
are not yet indicted from the disclosure
that they
were investigated for a crime under new
york law the prosecutor and jurors are
not allowed to reveal anything about the
presentation including testimony or
voting
it's a felony to disclose grand jury
information however
the secrecy doesn't extend to witnesses
so the hundred thousand dollar
question is an indictment against
members of the trump family imminent
well a few words of caution about
reports that donald trump is about to be
indicted first of all donald trump
is potentially not the only target of
this probe he may not even be a target
of this probe
officers of the company don jr and cfo
alan weisselberg could be implicated as
could ivanka or trump's sisters and of
course
in a similarly analogous situation
people over-invested in the mueller
investigation only to be let down when
mueller interpreted his mandate
very very narrowly saying that he wasn't
allowed to say whether
trump committed a crime or not which is
a source of great controversy to this
day
and scythance is not exactly captain
america either in january 2020 advocates
called on vance to resign because of his
pattern of allowing wealthy and powerful
defendants off the hook vance declined
to prosecute harvey weinstein in 2015.
he also
allegedly bungled the case against ob
gyn robert harden
who allegedly abused dozens of patients
vance arrested harden in 2012 but his
arrest was voided and he was allowed to
continue practicing
evelyn yang the wife of new york mayoral
candidate andrew yang said that she was
one of hardin's victims and she's
blasted vance along
with many of the other victims as well
now sources didn't exactly say how long
the grand jury has been meeting
a special grand jury proceeding lasts
for no longer than six months
if recently means they started a few
weeks ago then we could be waiting
several months before anything happens
uh
if we ever see anything at all if they
started to meet five months ago an
indictment or not
might be imminent though that seems
unlikely however if you're looking for
clues consider that it was just last
week that we learned that new york
attorney general tish james
now has two lawyers working with the
manhattan district attorney
it's relatively unusual for the attorney
general's office to team up
with the local district attorney they're
often turf wars and apparently that's
not happening here and
the revelation came right after james
announced that the state's civil
investigation of the trump organization
has evolved
into a criminal matter we don't know why
it's criminal but it may have something
to do with evidence that was developed
during the ongoing manhattan grand jury
process but remember i mentioned that
it's often
extremely easy to manipulate the grand
jury process by prosecutors that
also means that prosecutors can
manipulate it in the other direction
away
from an indictment if that's what they
want to do
if they would actually prefer not to
indict someone and we've already seen
this in
many police cases such as the case
involving the death of brianna taylor
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
is in hot water for allegedly lying
about what he presented to a grand jury
and allegedly sandbagging his own
efforts to procure
an indictment in that case but it
certainly looks like vance wants to
indict someone
but we can't assume anything right now
including the identity of that person
vance announced that he's stepping down
at the end of the year which is kind of
a strange move for someone who's about
to bring the highest profile case of his
entire lifetime but at the end of the
day if you have personally witnessed
illegal activity by the trump
organization or its members
you should call the authorities and you
can save money on that call by switching
to ting mobile
i personally switch to t-mobile and have
saved literally hundreds of dollars a
month
i'm not kidding here why because of this
yes that is a real cell phone bill that
i got with my previous provider
and it's why i personally switch to ting
and ting mobile has three brand new
plans to make sure that this
never happens again all of ting's plans
have unlimited talk and tech starting at
just ten dollars per month add data for
as little as five dollars per gigabyte
or choose a set of data or just go
full unlimited for 45 dollars a month
switching plans is really really easy
because you can keep your same phone
number and use pretty much any phone and
the service is great too because ting
partners with several massive networks
probably the very same one that you're
using right now but at a huge
discount they literally use the same
infrastructure now actually i can't tell
you which ones because i always respect
contracts
but let's just say that my service
hasn't changed at all
and it's incredibly easy to transfer
service using the exact same phone
number you have right now you just
order a ting sim card pop it in and set
it up you don't even have to call anyone
it's like magic so if you go to
legaleagle.ting.com or click on the link
in the description you can use your last
build to compare
just how much you would save and legal
eagles will also get a 25
service credit that could cover two
months of service so just click on the
link in the description and give it a
try
plus clicking on that link really helps
out this channel so do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this other legal
eagle video right here
i think you're really going to like it
so click on this video or i'll see you
in court